could you tell me a little bit about
metrics and how you guys went about
measuring things in the early days and
what was important to measure that's a
really good question because you're
you're pretty resource constrained early
on and every moment you spend
implementing some fancy analytic is is
one less moment you could be focusing on
your customers or your product but when
I look back I think there were a few
things that we tracked that really
helpful the first and and they're not
all numbers in fact the first was Dan my
co-founder set up an email that would
email everyone in the company every
single day and say here's the list of
everybody who signed up for our product
today and I remember being so excited
when you know I noticed somebody from
Starbucks had signed up or you know we'd
noticed this big company or this big
company that gave us a pretty simple way
to jump on these moments you know email
and say hey what's going on can we help
you and and I think some of our longest
lasting customer relationships started
through that so it's a really easy way
to plug in to what was actually
happening with our with our customers
the second one is is it sounds a little
funny actually
we made it impossible to fire Optimizely
without sending us an email so we didn't
build any way to unsubscribe from our
service instead we said if you want to
unsubscribe email Optimizely and we were
a little worried that people would be
really pissed off about this and one or
two were but it also gave us a really
really clear and quick way to understand
where we were screwing up and you know I
think where otherwise some of these
customers would have sort of silently
drifted into the night this gave us an
avenue to ask what was going wrong what
could we have done to have kept you as a
happy customer and we didn't earn them
all back and we probably didn't hurt
many of them back honest at first but it
was a pretty easy way just to find out
where we're screwing up and so I'd like
to think that the most important metrics
early on were the ones that helped us
stay attuned to to where we were
pleasing and where we were angry our
customers so given where the company is
currently what do you think is important
to measure and the next couple months or
years well we're a lot bigger now we're
hundreds of employees and we have
thousands of customers and we've gotten
a lot more sophisticated
in how we measure our financials as a
company so how we forecast gap revenue
analysis and all of that and that's been
very illuminating it's it's great as a
founder to be able to have that view
into your business one of the things
that we're trying to build out now I
mentioned this before is the ability to
measure customers in the same way and to
give everybody inside Optimizely this
same crystal-clear view of how our
customers are doing and how good the
experience we're giving them is and the
way we do that is with the Optimizely
promoter system I mentioned this before
it's it's a variant of NPS net promoter
system and we ask our customers a simple
question and we ask them to explain how
likely would they be to how likely would
they be to recommend Optimizely to a
friend or a colleague and based on that
answer and based on the reason they give
for their answer we get insights into
how well we're doing and it's pretty
easy to spot leading indicators which we
expect a later show up in the revenue
elsewhere you know if we're given our
customers a bad experience we'd expect
to see that in churn numbers but churn
is a trailing indicator we're doing our
best now to build leading indicators of
how well we're treating our customers
and that's a big challenge for us over
the next few years that sounds like it